hi everybody i'm brian keating a host of
the
into the impossible podcast and i'm here
to welcome you
to a fascinating episode an interview
between two friends uh
professor nicholas eunis of uh the
university of illinois urbana champaign
long name for a good university and
professor clifford will
university of florida chancellor's
professor of physics
these are two gentlemen who've written a
wonderful book called
is einstein still right so we've had a
lot of
einsteinian related podcasts from our
friend professor james gates
our friend professor matthew stanley uh
professor lee smullen has agreed to come
on the show in the near future as well
to discuss
his uh einstein's unfinished business
i think is the name of his book i'll
have him on soon he's a good friend long
time friend
so we'll have him on and now we have
this book about is einstein still right
of course professor jim gates's book was
proving einstein
right so he better be if uh if jim is
not to have to reissue his book under a
different title
but today you're going to learn some
fascinating things that i
am uh and really be bewitched by
including theories of everything i want
to get their impression we're often told
you need a theory of everything to unify
quantum mechanics with gravity but who
says that's actually
mandatory who says that gravity and
quantum mechanics have to be
married together and we'll hear from
clifford will who's one of the pioneers
has worked with kip thorne for his phd
at caltech in the 60s
he's one of the greybeards literally
in this field and wonderful perspective
a wonderful delightful book
you'll learn about what gravitational
waves teach us you'll learn the physics
behind the nobel prize that was awarded
this year to roger penrose andrea guez
and reiner genzel
you'll learn about that and it's not
watered down but it's not
intimidatingly technical there are no
equations in the entire book
and the most delightful part of the book
is really seeing the perspective of a
young
person in this case nico eunis in
conversation with
with an older gentleman who happens to
be cliff will
and getting their perspectives very
disparate but united in
the and the kind of magic that is
einstein and
in some sense his unfinished quest still
continues
and we're still revealing some of the
truths of what you would say is maybe
his finished quest maybe his finest
quest which was general relativity
sit back enjoy the ride into the
impossible today
please do me a favor just go down in
your podcast uh
catcher where are you listening to this
rate the into the impossible podcast
give it any kind of writing you desire
and leave a review and please check out
their book
is einstein still right welcome
to into the impossible
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
welcome everybody to this edition of
pandemic podcasting as part of the
arthur c
clarke center for human imagination i am
your fearful host
professor brian keating co-director of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination
and today it's a treat to have uh not
only two fellow physicists
but uh two incredibly engaging
interesting
and fascinating authors of a wonderful
new book
called is einstein still right
and so we'll be talking about that book
most of today but i'm also going to take
this opportunity because how often do i
get a chance to talk to
luminaries such as nico eunis and
clifford will who are my guests today
and i want to talk to them about some
topics that i've had been discussing on
the into the impossible podcast a lot
lately including
einstein so i've had on this is now the
third
podcast just dedicated to einstein i
have a fourth one coming up soon
hopefully with uh
lisa mullen who's a friend of both of
yours i know
and that will be about his book uh
einstein's unfinished revolution i think
is the name of it so it's funny because
einstein has a book about his war
with professor matthew matt stanley he's
got a
a book about is he still right and then
i have a book
called proving einstein right by
professor jim gates who is on the
podcast earlier this year
and uh so there's a lot of einstein in
the air but first let's get to our two
guests who are no slouches themselves
first up professor clifford will
a legend a a titan in the field
he is the distinguished professor of
physics at the university of florida in
gainesville florida
he's also involved in the institute for
fundamental theory the institute for
high energy physics and astrophysics
and he's written numerous books given
tons of papers and what i most
really respected about cliff is that
he's one of the few people that
has done it all he's done everything
from work done
aspects of experiments to test various
phenomena
mostly in gravitational physics to pure
theory to phenomenology
the data analysis uh this this is a man
who can do it all
cliff how are you doing today in the
southern wilds of our countries
well very very well of course it turns
out i live on the beach near st
petersburg so
so it's a very pleasant surrounding so
yeah
florida's very nice these days
i'm wearing shorts all day long
not the people in michigan and you know
new york got to feel bad but
that's right or illinois as the case may
be in the case of professor anika younis
who
received his bachelor's degree from
washington university in st
louis in 2003 and his phd from penn
state university in 2008
he was at princeton he had an einstein
fellowship i want to see if that
influenced him
when he was at mit and harvard and then
he was a professor
at montana state university for eight
years and recently last year he became a
professor
at the university of illinois and he's
the director of the illinois center
for advanced studies of the universe
that is very intriguing nico how are you
we've known each other for a long time
it's our first time really doing a
podcast together how are you sir
i'm very good thank you so much for
having us uh you know i am not
uh i don't have an apartment uh by the
beach
you know well there's a lake there's a
lake near nearby i've heard it's pretty
great
that's correct but you know the dynamic
times were pretty much
all uh you know staying home
and you know dealing with kids and all
of that stuff
yeah we'll get to that uh when we talk
about the differences between the two of
you you guys
are kind of like the uh the original odd
couple when it comes to this uh
young and old you know different
backgrounds and different
uh different interests but i want to get
to the book first and foremost
i found it very delightful i consumed it
very quickly
it's an easy read it's it's dense the
book is actually
surprisingly dense you know you pick it
up and you think it's like a paperback
like um you know this piece of uh
of news junk over here that i wrote uh
but it's uh it's about eight times more
dense than that so
i want to commend you first of all on
the on the printing and the binding of
the book
but what i always like to do is ask the
authors um
unlike the advice to never judge a book
by its cover i always judge books by
their covers
i think most people do uh where'd you
guys come up with the
with the title and uh how did you come
up with the cover design it sort of
depicts a
a colorized version of of america's uh
or the world's most famous physicist
title and cover design how did it go
either one of you
well the the title the title was pretty
easy because uh
30 years ago more than 30 is pushing 34
years ago
um i wrote a book called was einstein
right
so jessica was it was last century
that was in the last century right long
before nico was born
and it did pretty well but it described
the tests of gr
up to general relativity up to that
point
and so um and this
in some ways gets to how we decided to
write this book
but first of all if you want to sell a
book about science
you should have einstein in the title so
that was that was a given
and then anything with a question mark
is good because people wonder you know
is einstein's fine right
but now today because we're you know
there are these things on the horizon
that may make us
think about going beyond einstein like
the acceleration of the universe
the problem of quantum gravity and so on
it's
it's a nice question to ask is he still
right we believe the answer is
yes but still implies that in the future
there's still room possibly
to go beyond einstein so that that part
of the title came
you know we we agreed within a
millisecond that that was
our basic title and nico what about the
uh cover design the art yeah there's
a lot of uh a lot of back and forth
between oxford and us about the cover
design the design
was was made by artists at the
publishing house
and we considered multiple different
alternatives and we looked at other
books that have been published in the
past 10 years and looked at their covers
and went to make sure that ours was not
too
similar to other people's but still like
attractive and engaging
and you would just catch your eye and be
like oh yeah you know that's a book i
want to like
open um and you know
a lot of of what we talk
not all of it but a good chunk of the
book deals with gravitational waves
because
not only because they got the nobel
prize of years ago but also because it
was a huge demonstration of einstein's
uh of the theory success of predict
predicting something and then
spending 50 years to build the machines
and
you know create the theory or sorry
develop the theory
and develop the data analysis tools to
be able to really verify this prediction
of
of
einsteins um so we thought you know well
we should depict gravitational waves
somehow on the cover
that's why it's like all sort of on you
lady
and of course you know you have to have
the man
and the back cover sort of is evocative
of a black hole
sort of uh maybe emerging black hole
merging with the oxford university press
logo which uh you know surprisingly for
a publisher they made that
their black hole much smaller than yours
but um uh
i want to talk about you know the
timeliness of the book so you
you mention essentially everybody uh
who's won a nobel prize
which is not surprising as the readers
of my book losing the nobel prize will
will recognize the nobel prize as sort
of a catechism or sort of a
a way of bestowing uh idolatry or
bestowing upon laureates this kind of uh
everlasting
um uh appraised that some say you know
in some cases the
the winner of the nobel prize gives
prestige to the prize
in other words some people win the prize
and it gives them great prestige
in the case of einstein i think drac and
feynman others
sort of conceived that by winning the
prize they almost did a favor
for uh for the uh for the nobel prize
itself
and of course einstein looms large nico
had a fellowship named after him
uh after um einstein uh cliff
just the next year you're going to win
the einstein prize of the american
physical society he's already won the
impression
that's right well exactly a hundred
years uh
go to the year since einstein had the
same thing happen he
he won the 2021 nobel prize but he
didn't receive it until 2022 so
cliff you're in good company um so
the biggest changes obviously is that as
you guys discuss
in the end section where we're going to
get to maybe at the end of this
discussion you guys have a dialogue uh
young and old uh pretty and handsome i
don't know you guys are both handsome uh
but the uh but the point is uh you guys
don't forget wise wise yes brilliant and
wise yes nico is quite wise
but but the um but the changes that
you've seen cliff
let's talk about that starting as a
young graduate student
meeting folks like you talk about kip
thorne uh
you know who is to become a noble list
himself uh what what what do you
attribute this massive
uh increase in testing something which
einstein himself correct me if i'm wrong
he never thought any of the
gravitational lensing was an oddity
gravitational waves would never be
detected
so he got a lot of things wrong right
well i mean wrong but it was right for
his time the technology in his day
didn't didn't exist at all to
uh you know to to to see the some of the
things he calculated
i mean we now know that gravitational
lenses exist
light can be bent by distant galaxies
but in einstein
say it was not known that there were
galaxies outside the milky way
so you know based on what he knew he he
did the best he could
right but i was lucky enough to to be
enter caltech i was a graduate student
of capricorn at a time when
astronomical discoveries like of quasars
pulsars
the cosmic background radiation from the
big bang these all took place in the 60s
combined with the new technology of
the space program atomic clocks high
precision
laser tracking of things all came
together right around this time
60s and early 70s to on the one hand
make general relativity relevant for
astronomy that just caused a huge amount
of interest
to grow in the theory but at the same
time provided the kinds of
tools that you could use to test it to
make sure it was right
and nico when you got into this game
obviously a lot had happened that kept
talked about we knew about gravitational
lensing
we hadn't detected gravitational waves
but um you know we detected planets
around other
uh or stars in the in the galaxy using
gravitational
uh or using physical effects doppler
ships etc
what drew you into this field as a young
person in the in the early part of the
of this millennium as you keep pointing
out the cliff are much
you know much older than you guys yeah
so for me i grew up in argentina i went
to school there i started university
there
and so i came to the us with uh what we
call football scholarship but it's not
your football it's you know
the other football it's just that's just
what 99.7 percent of the world calls it
and even though um
i had this scholarship i knew ahead of
time that i wanted to do physics so you
see in argentina you still have to
decide what area you want to specialize
in when you like register for university
so i knew it was physics i knew it was
theoretical physics i wasn't quite sure
exactly what kind of theoretical physics
i wanted to do
but i was always fascinated by sci-fi
and in particular by star trek
and i thought like black holes were
really cool
androids were really really cool and
being able to like you know understand
what happens close to a black hole or
close to a neutron star those were like
fascinating topics that's what i wanted
to study
but it was not until i got to washu
where cliff was a professor and he was
head of the department at the time
that um i realized that you know the
field that studies all those things
within physics was like general
relativity
uh gravitation and there was this
awesome gravitational growth had washer
at the time with professor weymouth
and matt visser and cliff and you know
it was purpose like okay this is this is
what i want to do
and you know of course you know as i was
beginning to learn about gr and so on
pretty much everyone especially in grad
school everyone i talked to
you know pretty much questioned why
would you why would you go into
gravitational waves nobody's going to
detect gravitational waves we don't even
know those exist
gr what's gr i mean we all know jared is
right why are you wasting your
time doing this you know come do
condensed matter
or you know look at this fascinating
materials and this quantum mechanics
that we can actually measure in the lab
which i thought was super cool
but you know i i stuck to my guns and
it's like you know i
i knew as a kid that i wanted to
understand black holes and you know i'm
just very stubborn
so she's gonna continue trying to study
that
and it paid off uh by some sort of
miracle uh
you know when i was a grad student uh
pretoria's
uh succeeded in uh completing the first
numerical simulation of two merging
black holes so you could see how two
black
holes uh how if you evolve the einstein
equations and clusters of supercomputers
for
many many weeks sometimes months you
could see visualizations of these black
holes
spiraling into each other and colliding
and forming
a very distorted monster that would just
bring down and then suddenly to a
stationary black hole and you could see
all these gravitational waves and that
was a huge break that was the biggest
breakthrough i had seen
uh at that time um
so so you know that gave me hope and
and sure enough you know about 10 years
later
ligo would detect the first
gravitational waves
yeah so uh nico you're the second
argentinian at least to my knowledge
that's been on the into the impossible
podcast the first
to my knowledge was juan maldasena who
is
no slouch when it comes to theoretical
physics and he and i had a wonderful
conversation
a couple of weeks ago about wormholes
and other exotic features of quantum
mechanics married with
general relativity and you guys
mentioned this a lot in your book and i
can't resist because i have an interest
in in things such as the theory theories
of everything
i want to ask you um why why is it
important
that there be a theory of everything uh
and either one of you guys can answer
this question not just argentinians
uh well so since uh you talked to juan
juan
is amazing uh i think in fact i haven't
an anecdote he probably doesn't remember
but uh i contacted him when i was in
argentina as a high school student and
my name was like hey i'm this young kid
and i think he replied and and i feel
super nice and then i got to meet him um
at the institute of advanced status when
i was a postdoc at princeton
and he was always super nice to me
incredibly smart guy
of course you know so
so why do we want a theory a theory of
everything
in part it's because we know that every
time in the history of physics every
time we've unified
what seemed like disjoint theories the
new phenomena emerged
new predictions could be made and and
sometimes true revolutions
uh in the field uh would would appear
right so
einstein is a classic example when he
unified
electromagnetism um with uh
you know the concept of classical
mechanics and newtonian gravitation and
and made these theories compatible with
each other then
a slew of other phenomena and
consequences emerged
and so in some sense the hope is that
something like that
will also occur that by unifying uh
quantum mechanics
with with relativity we'll we'll get a
deeper understanding
of of the cosmos and new phenomena will
will will be predicted that we will be
able to observe maybe new technology
will have to be built in order to make
those measurements
and and push engineering forward as well
um so so part of it i think is that
from a physicist's point of view i think
uh
pretty much everyone i know of would
agree after
uh enough alcohol consumption that
uh we are very deeply dissatisfied with
the current status
of of of things right we have two
theories that are incredibly successful
in the regimes of validity
but that seem to be incompatible and
and that's that's just not
it's not it's not fulfilling
it just makes you think that there's
something else that we're missing
there's a piece of the puzzle
it's like we're trying to put this
puzzle together this jigsaw puzzle
but somebody has removed some of the
pieces
but you know there should be a piece
right here but you just can't find it on
the table it's like your little
six-year-old just
took six or seven pieces away from the
table and now you're going crazy trying
to figure out what should go there right
yeah but the hardest puzzles are the
ones that have no pictures on the front
right so
cliff is there any guarantee that there
needs to be
a theory of everything i mean we'd all
like it it'd be pretty it'd be beautiful
but uh we know that many of our desires
in life are
unfulfilled uh you know uh i i wanted to
be in a in a corn maze this weekend with
nico but i can't do it
so and in what sense are we you know
maybe pursuing a fool's errand that
there may not be a theory of everything
well i mean i think it's that is
certainly a possibility i mean we
this desire this this desire for
unification
is uh is a human desire and it's not
clear that nature actually follows what
humans want
i mean so so while i respect the desire
and and in some ways i'm fascinated by
it i'm
totally open to the to the idea that
it's possible that
there is no quantum theory of gravity
there doesn't need to be
um and that these two fundamental
theories quantum mechanics and gr
just are always going to be incompatible
with each other
they'll be friendly and they'll you know
they'll socially distance and
communicate with each other at some
level
but they're never going to just totally
get it together
so i'm i'm open to that idea although
i'm certainly respect the people who
want to work on it the big problem is
uh and since i'm as you mentioned so
heavily embedded
in experiment in the idea of experiments
although i i don't do experiments nobody
ever allows me in their lab because it's
usually a disaster but
it the idea of experiment view is so
important
and even the practitioners of these
unified theories in quantum gravity
admit that
it's very difficult to conceive of
experiments that could actually tell you
whether
any of these ideas are correct or which
ideas are correct which ones are
incorrect
the experiments are for the most part
out of the realm of what we could
conceivably perform and so that to me
gets to another issue of what is
what is a scientific decision then if
you if you can't really verify something
experimentally so there's that part of
it swirling around too in
when you discuss these of everything but
as the great uh
sage physicist yogi berra once said
uh yeah it's very tough to make
predictions especially about the future
and you know einstein thought that this
calculation i think there was a mr
mandel or somebody who came to him
asking about
a little calculation having to do uh
with bending of light
uh you know by gravity you know it's
gravitational lensing what we call weak
lensing nowadays
and he didn't think much of it i love
the way that his little note to the
editor of nature
you know is basically published accepted
on site but
he also died without you know achieving
this unification that we desired and
i want to keep going on the theory of
everything just for one more minute
because it's not so often i get to speak
to a genius such as yourself
nico no for both of you guys
cliff or nico um usually the standard
and i've read about a half a dozen of
these books in the last year
that say well because you know there are
singularities at the center of black
holes and that the universe began with
the singularity
um there must be a unification
of gravity with quantum mechanics
because we can't understand things at
the microscopic scale let alone the
infinitesimal scale
first of all is there is there any
evidence for singularities at any point
in the universe uh today in the deep
past i mean
uh is there any physical evidence that
one could ever get the issue that i have
is that a singularity is is like an
infinite it's an infinity it's something
that doesn't
exist in the physical world there's no
example of something that's infinite
in the physical world i mean correct me
if i'm wrong except for as
einstein once said human stupidity
perhaps but
uh but tell us uh you know why why is it
that that's always pointed to as
evidence for the need for
a quantum theory of gravity the
existence of singularities i claim we
don't have any evidence for
singularities as yet physical evidence
all right i mean from one point of view
the the one class of singularities that
appear inside black holes
we actually can never get evidence of
such singularities because there are
whatever garbage might come out of that
singularity is always
hidden inside the event horizon and will
never affect the outside world
so to someone who's skeptical of these
ideas that's one answer
they're there sure but nobody ever has
to worry about them because they're
always behind an event horizon
ah and you could have evidence right i
mean we could just throw brian into the
black hole and let him
let him let him you can't destroy
infinite amounts of intelligence
it's impossible um but the other black
hole
the other singularity in some ways is
more significant i mean
obviously the universe started from an
incredibly state of very high density
very
you know tight compaction of everything
classical general relativity says that
that actually has to be a space-time
singularity everything
really has to be infinite this in fact
it was one of the many things that roger
penrose
proved along with stephen hawking about
the
cosmic singularity if you believe
standard general relativity
it literally must be infinite no way
around it
so there i think the argument that if
you want to really understand
the origin of the universe you have to
bring in quantum mechanics
that argument to me makes a little more
is a little more cogent
than the one about the singularities
inside black holes interesting
nico you've worked a lot with cmb probes
and talk about that actually that's the
one
bone i wanted to pick with you guys
there's very little mention of my
precious b
modes and primordial gravitational waves
in this book but nico
i was on purpose i was on purpose okay
you're excluding me i i knew it you have
an
anti-cheating bias a bicep bias
but i want to know uh when we think
about uh i've often heard it said
even by my colleagues and friends who
shall remain
nameless that if we detect b modes that
will be
from primordial uh gravitational waves
that would be evidence
of quantum gravity can you talk a little
bit about that
is that is that really does that have
the ring of truth so to speak in your
opinion that detection of primordial b
modes is tantamount
to detection of the quantum gravity
epoch
well right so so there are these ideas
that have been put forth
about ways to um
try to construct something close to an
a quantum theory of gravity right so so
pretty much everyone has heard of
string theory although if you ask the
general public that
probably nobody understands what that
means um
and and other efforts have been made as
well uh to unify general relativity
with quantum mechanics such as for
example loop quantum gravity who uh
lee smalling for example has worked a
lot on and you mentioned will be
on your show and later so
what a lot of these quantum theories
have in common
is that they predict that certain
effects should be present
at sufficiently high uh energies and
that's officially large curvatures
and one of these effects is uh one
that's called uh or is it's labeled
party violation
um or party breaking and so some people
uh
so we could go into like a long
mathematical discussion that i don't
want to get into
about exactly what those uh how those
terms are represented
uh at the level of of the theory but the
bottom line
is that some of these quantum
gravitational effects
should sort of percolate into into
observations
through uh these these b modes and
through a breaking of
parity that could be present in in the b
modes so if you could see these b modes
then you could say
something about parity violation in
gravity
um and then that would have to be built
on top of einstein's theory because
einstein's theory doesn't
doesn't describe that i'm not a party
violation and that's important like
looking for
ways to experimentally prove whether
what we think of fundamental symmetries
are really true symmetries of nature
that's super key
right um you know
things like uh lorenz invariants
right that sort of led einstein to
impart to the development of of special
relativity and general relativity
looking for violations of that would be
revolutionary right if you if you did an
experiment and you saw that
gravitationally there's a violation of
variant symmetry that would indicate
that there's
in some sense perhaps a preferred
direction uh
or in space-time that our theory would
have to
to deal with and general relativity is
not equipped for doing that because it's
built on the axioms
uh that that einstein postulated and
those axioms do not allow
for the breakage of that symmetry at the
classical level even if that breaking is
weak for example we had i had a
conversation with sean carroll
on friday on my channel that was
revolving around a claimed
piece of evidence for cosmic
birefringence so cairo chiral
behavior of the electromagnetic vacuum
consistent with adding a lorentz and
parity breaking
four vector to the electromagnetic
lagrangian
in this case we know it would have to be
you know incredibly small because we
could only detect it via
the traversal of photons since the last
scattering surface to today
or to the planck satellite this is a
paper by miami and
um and uh and ichiro kamatsu
that shawn and i were talking about that
claimed evidence for this effect
or you know weak evidence at this level
but uh
but is it true that if you break
lorenzen variants we'd have to get rid
of
uh gr altogether what if it's just a
tiny bit of uh you know
of violation like we observe in the weak
sector we don't throw out the
you know on maxwell's equations right
and that's that's a great point and i
think there's a point that we we make in
the book uh quite a bit
it's about the self-correcting nature of
science you know when you when you
are confronted with an experiment that
suggests that your previous theory
is not quite right or the predictions of
your theory are not quite right you
don't just grab that here and you throw
it in the trash
what rather you do is you try to figure
out
what that theory is missing so you can
add to that theory
this new interaction that would predict
the new observation or at least explain
the new observation you've made and
hopefully also predict
new phenomena that you can observe uh so
at no point
so and this is essential right because
you want to make sure that your new
theory with these amendments that you've
made
is still able to explain and predict all
of the other phenomena that you've
observed over the past like millennia
right um so it's not like when we say
einstein's theory of general relativity
proved newton wrong
it's not that newton's theory is
completely invalid it's not that if
we are trying to calculate um how
uh you know projectile motion or or you
know how to launch
a satellite out of earth so that it's in
orbit
it's not that we have to solve the
theories of the equations of einstein i
mean we still for the most part use
newtonian mechanics because
in the regime where we're doing this
experiments newtonian mechanics is
perfectly valid
and deviations to newtonian predictions
are
truly minuscule in the solar system uh
really hard to measure
um so i don't know belief i've been
talking for a long time
no in fact we're careful to say in
various parts of the book
that when we talk about possibly
modifying general relativity
for example as a possible
explanation for the acceleration of the
universe the accelerated
expansion of the universe we talk about
in terms of beyond einstein rather than
you know
overthrowing so whatever theory you need
to construct has to agree with general
relativity and all the realms
and the realms are now passed over which
it's been verified
to high precision but then this theory
then can do something slightly different
in these other regimes like the the
large-scale cosmological regime
yeah and i think let me just uh play off
of that idea cliff because i think this
is also something that that we mentioned
in the book and it's very important
is the idea of of a scientific fact uh
there there are certain things uh in
science
that are scientific truths and and we
don't
so people agree on this on these
concepts
and different communities are not
entitled to their own
set of of truths we all sort of come
together
and decide through experiment whether a
particular prediction is correct
or not and if there's a prediction or if
there's an observation that
you know seems to disagree with a
prediction of a well-known theory that
has been tested
to that day what we do is we repeat the
experiment
and we ask the people that did the first
experiment to check that you know all
the cables have been properly plugged in
and that you know before you jump and do
a press release
and bring bottles of champagne to the
creators of the theory you need to make
absolutely sure
that that what you've observed is is
really what you thought you observed and
other people
can reproduce that observation that
really hurts
thank you thank you for sticking it to
me yeah it actually reminds me of a
quote by none other than isaac asimov
uh in a in a piece that he wrote called
the relativity of
wrong and you guys mentioned this
briefly in passing in the book but he
says
isaac asimov was writing to somebody who
really believed the
world was flat and he wrote when people
thought the earth was flat they were
wrong
when people thought the earth was
spherical they were wrong but if you
think that thinking the earth is
spherical it's just as wrong as thinking
the earth is flat
then your view is wronger than both of
them put together
and i think that that's uh you know kind
of beautifully
uh apropos of uh some of the things you
point out in the
in this book what you guys are doing
what you're talking about what we
physicists are doing is incredibly hard
we're trying to test something to see if
it breaks when we know it's past
tests to the you know 10 decimal place
and beyond in the case of the you know
binary pulsar that you guys talked about
uh but i know cliff provided me some
slides i want to see cliff are you able
to share your screen right now
and we'll uh we'll go through your uh
your slide
show and uh and then we'll wrap up with
some questions about the uh the dialogue
oh and that you guys conducted at the
end of the book which i found so
delightful
so please take away the screen right
so is it is it sharing yes
that's just a brief promo for the book
i'm an unabashed
promoter so i will say that uh
the part of the book covers you know
it's we really talk about the kinds of
experiments that have been done to
verify general relativity so we talk
about famous experiments like the
bending of starlight
tested in 1919 by
arthur stanley eddington uh that those
were measurements that made einstein an
international celebrity
this bending has been tested many many
times recently including by an amateur
astronomer and
during the eclipse american eclipse of
2017
who used off-the-shelf equipment and did
a better job than the astronomers in
1919 in terms of
accuracy and we talk about how time the
rate of time depends on the
where you are in a gravitational field
and so on
but really the bulk of the book is talks
about more recent stuff
like detecting the motions of stars near
the black hole at the arc galactic
center which
was rewarded with the nobel prize part
of the nobel prize just a few weeks ago
we talk about the black hole shadows
produced by the event horizon telescope
then we turn to gravitational waves and
we really give the full story
of how gravitational waves were detected
the ins and outs the backstory
we explain gravitational waves we
even actually even show how to convince
yourself that the gravitational waves
were really detected and then we
conclude with this uh
this dialogue between the wise person
and the young person
the one thing the book has thanks to
uh the uh my artistic collaborator
p point his first name is power um
we have very simple line drawings we
didn't want to get fancy or exotic
but simple line drawings to try to
illustrate you know what's going on we
tried to explain the event horizon of a
black hole by talking about a swimmer
swimming upstream before going over
niagara falls and
we describe how the interferometers work
in ligo
we describe what what the gravitational
wave actually was doing as it approached
the solar system from the south side of
the solar system
um things like that we talk about ligo
its construction
its development we describe the first
detection the first waves this is almost
raw data that they
uh that they collected just filtered in
a minimal way
and just looking at the peaks and
troughs and how they are the same in the
two detectors
anybody can convince him for herself
that this was
from outside the solar system this is a
wave detected from somewhere else you
just look at these peaks
they're the same uh you know exactly the
same it's actually about
seven milliseconds apart but that's the
because of the distance between the two
detectors so
we try our best to use simple language
to explain these things
and for example in the um uh we also
describe
how as one of these stars orbited very
close to the black hole at the center of
our galaxy
the the light from the star was reddened
because of the this this redshift effect
of einstein
this star was only a um a hundred times
the earth
sun distance from the black hole and so
it was very
deep in the heart of that gravity field
until the light from that star was red
and
has a reached us and that was measured
this of course is an artist's rendition
not real
photographs um so
and this of course is we spent a fair
amount of time discussing the stars at
the center of our galaxy
and this is a an animation based on the
actual data
showing the star is the center of the
galaxy
the these moving dots are the actual
stars orbiting
this star with the yellow orbit is the
star called s2
it has now completed about one and a
half orbits
around the black hole and uh two years
ago
in may of 2018 it passed very close to
the black hole
and that produced that measurement of
the gravitational redshift that you saw
so we describe all these and of course
the book came out just in time
for andrew aguez and weinhard denzel the
leaders of the two teams
to win the nobel prize of course they
point out in the citation
the word black hall does not get
mentioned it just says there's a
compact object yeah i mean because i
mean the trouble is to really prove it's
a black hole you have to go into it
but then you can't write a paper to win
your next nobel prize
well that's when they're graduate that's
what graduate students are for right
nico that's right
but but i think the idea is to to prove
you know that it's such a compact thing
that it can't be anything else
but by the way with things like this
orbiting close to the black hole
we can start to prove aspects of the
nature of the curve space-time
close enough to the black hole that you
can really
get to a higher level of proving that it
has to be a black hole without ever
you know going through the event horizon
so and we
so we talk about this future that we're
only at the beginning of
testing general relativity testing the
nature of black holes
with these kinds of incredible
observations
yeah i mean if it smells like a duck
looks like a duck
you don't have to like cook it and taste
to ensure that it's stuck
but if it's an invisible duck made of uh
what are black holes made of actually i
me this is a question i get a lot how do
you guys answer that what
you go inside a black hole what's it
made of it protons neutrons croutons
doesn't keep thorns say that it's full
of love
that's how you get to it would say that
and
and will be royalties
good one will cliff that's great um
black holes are formed by the collapse
of matter right uh
this matter can be of all different
forms it could be gas
it could be charged particles
and so when all of this material
collapses eventually it's dense enough
that an
event horizon like we call it forms and
it dynamically grows to the size it's
going to be
and stop growing um
and so inside the black hole
you know if the black hole is isolated
there's nothing else around it let's see
just imagine that there's no
interstellar gas or anything else in the
universe just like
the black hole after it's formed then
there's really nothing inside of the
black hole
except for at the very point of this
like at the center
if it's not rotating at the singularity
where all of the matter that formed it
from a collapse would be located
and that's where all of the energy the
pressure and so on are infinite
and where our classical description of
space-time breaks down what's the most
fascinating
aspect of gr of einstein
to you guys is it uh you guys have the
first coherent description of the lens
theory effect
uh maybe you talk about that for a
second uh
how do you think about that that's sort
of one of the most interesting and it
takes up a good chunk of
chapter two or three i can't remember um
and and it took a
large chunk of the u.s uh you know
gravitational
research budget uh from 1959 or so
to uh just a few years ago in gp gravity
probe b
talk about the lens steering effect why
is it so important uh what are we
interested in
and uh couldn't we have saved a lot of
money and just given that money to
andrea guezz and she could have shown it
using the images that you just showed
i mean this this experiment is in many
ways close to my heart
because i wasn't i was not directly
involved in it but i chaired a
an external committee on behalf of nasa
to oversee
aspects of the of the project but
at first this effect is very important
for two reasons one
it's a prediction of general relativity
that literally does not exist in
newtonian theory i mean it really is
a purely relativistic result that a
rotating body can
effectively drag space and time around
with it and cause forces that can affect
body
simply due to the rotation this
phenomenon simply doesn't exist
in in newtonian theory
but in many ways the most more important
reason the interest
that's attached to it is because it
undoubtedly plays a role in things like
quasars
and black holes at the centers of the
galaxies you know people
you see these images of a bright
emission from the center of a galaxy
with an enormous jet
coming away from the black hole often in
both directions
um and then people often ask me lay
people out well how can the stuff be
coming out of the black hole
you know once it's in can you ever
escape but the point is that
stuff going around just outside the
black hole the swirling of ionized gas
coupled with these effects that cause
space-time
to be dragged around the hole the way
batter is dragged by a rotating
beater that combination can produce
forces on
charged particles that actually repel
them from the black hole
and many many models and theories have
been developed
to account for these jets and this
effect plays an intrinsic role
and so this experiment uh to try to
measure this effect precisely
using the rotating earth as the basis
was as you say conceived in the late
1950s
began development in the roughly late
60s
and ultimately became a space program
that
ran in the early 2000s so it took a very
long time
almost 50 years cost about 750 million
dollars
so it was very expensive to measure one
number
and so needless to say this experiment
still under a lot of criticism
and one of the things we do in our book
is try to discuss this issue
you know how as a case study and how
how you make decisions about about
experiments
and projects how do you weigh cost
versus
the scientific knowledge gained how do
you
deal with different communities the
astronomers very wanted to cancel gpb
physicists were more uh more positive
toward
because it was a fundamental physics
experiment so how do you balance
different different communities when you
try to consider priorities
so we try to for the lay reader give a
bit of a sense of
how how scientists struggle with you
know justifying
experiments based on cost and importance
and nico uh in terms of general
relativity's next
century what are you looking forward to
what what sorts of tests what sorts of
observations
what sorts of new theories might come
about that might uh
challenge you and have to do a you know
second edition
with uh two question marks or in chess
we use these
exclamation points that means brilliancy
and uh exclamation point and a
and a and a uh question mark is a
blunder i guess
uh what what are you looking forward to
in the future in the aspects of
relativity itself
yeah i think the future is super bright
when it comes to
to this field we're really at the dawn
of a lot but that's lucky for a young
guy like nico
everything is great we're gonna do
awesome just
you just wait cliff
um well i mean yeah so i i am honestly
optimistic about it especially like now
that
they're having so many advances in the
field both uh
in data analysis in technology in theory
um so i guess
there's two main things that i i'm
really looking forward to and i think
are going to be
discovered uh or done very soon one of
them is
a little bird told me that at some point
b-modes would be discovered
oh really that was an exclusive that was
uh
my source said you cannot mention that
on this on this podcast
at some point i think we'll get we'll
get a better sense of the polarization
of the cmb
and and i think cosmology is is quite
ripe for new discoveries there are
things that we don't fully understand uh
when it comes to cosmological
observations and we attribute the
adjective dark to them because we don't
understand them
but that um so i i think progress can be
made there and through more observations
uh that i think is what really going to
fit this progress it can't just be
theoretical ideas we really need
guidance from observations um
so so so so cosmological observations of
the cmb i think are going to be
very interesting and then the second
thing i think is going to be super
interesting is gravitational waves
and i don't just say that because that's
one of the fields that
uh that i identify with but also because
ligo just essentially turned on
you know metaphorically speaking
yesterday really it's a very new
experiment
and it hasn't even reached its design
sensitivity the sensitivity the the
accuracy
that it was built to achieve um
and i always tell the story that if you
if you um you know build an amplifier
you you don't when the first time you
put it together
you don't crank the volume to 15 and
just let it go right like you
you sort of one of my kids does
but you're going to get instruments are
super expensive they're super
complicated you
you turn it on slowly and and you you
you fill with it and and you increase
sensitivity little by little and that's
what they've been doing and they've been
doing great
and the amount of engineering there's a
lot of unsung heroes
and that's also something we try to do
in the book to describe the all the work
that has gone
uh into doing creating these experiments
and so the bottom line is these
instruments should
achieve design sensitivity by 2025 or so
so that's like five years from now and
there's already plans to
to build the next generation of
detectors
either in space through something called
lisa
or through what we call third generation
detectors on earth
which may be very very large or maybe
buried underground to
to increase their sensitivity and
estimates right now
say that once we reach those third
generation detectors with
lisa and uh so with lisa in space
and with the ground-based ones we would
be able to see the gravitational waves
emitted by all sources
all compact binaries in the universe
ever period
that's awesome to say we can
we can see all of neutron stars that
have ever merged
or will will ever merge um in the
universe and the amount of them for
astrophysical information
that's going to provide it it's really
outstanding
from the point of view of test of gr
there there's things that we currently
can't
um really test for because the data is
just not sensitive enough it's just not
loud enough or the systems that we've
observed
are not just right to test this
particular effect
but you know as we detect millions and
tens of millions of sources
and i'm talking now not in 2025 or like
2035
2040 then then this test will will
really
uh be very very powerful yeah if there's
a deviation in gr in binary mergers
um and we don't see them by them
then i would say there aren't any
so barry barish and kip thorne um
have agreed to come on the into the
impossible podcast after hearing that i
got you two guys
on the podcast so i will ask them uh
whatever questions you uh suggest
so please send them to me uh they'll be
coming in the next few weeks uh
hopefully we'll get those out
commemorating
uh this amazing epoch that we're in i've
heard it likened to you know somebody
saying oh what good are gravitational
waves we detected black holes
as as being akin to asking you know
galileo in 1610 of
is this telescope useful for anything
besides looking at the moons of jupiter
as if that wasn't enough i want to
conclude with galileo who's my hero
and uh and he has uh he has a lot of uh
you know kind of influence on my career
and the way i perceive scientists
uh and the way that we do our craft and
your book concludes with
not necessarily an homage to the great
maestro as he preferred to be called i
actually asked my grad students to call
me maestro
but but it concludes with a dialogue of
sorts uh there's only two of you not
three of you as in the famous dialogue
and the discoursee
his two final books uh and that galileo
wrote
which was written in platonic style but
i was thinking as i was reading at cliff
if you could go back in time
and advise a young mr will back
in in the 60s when he was first
attending graduate school would you have
told him to take the career path that
you ended up taking or
are there other things honestly that
that young mr will
should be should have been studying
besides this field
i mean from a practical point of view he
you know like
most of physics he should have been
studying you know
solid state or condensed metaphysics
that's where the jobs are right
if you're really rich in getting a job
it's the biggest
branch of physics it has the most
applications and so on and so forth
um you know it's hard to answer the
question with hindsight
but in in in many ways how i started out
was i think how a lot of students
started in their careers it was just
pure luck i mean i arrived at caltech
not knowing
that tip thorn existed because he was so
new to the faculty he was not listed in
their
brochure that they sent me
i didn't know about general relativity i
didn't learn any of my undergraduate
college there was such a new field no
one taught it
and i just happened to be you know
advised by
my some fellow canadian students whom i
knew i was canadian at the time
to go talk to this new professor
he's kind of weird-looking and has a
strange name
you know kip what is that right just go
talk to him and find out what he's doing
and so i did and sort of the rest is
history as they said
so to me it was a very contingent thing
i mean i just really had no
idea what i was doing and i think a lot
of students are that way and they kind
of
fall into a good situation and then
you know then they go on from there but
to me
certainly today i would advise anyone to
think about this as a career because
it's really has an exciting future it's
a substantial field it was it was a
really tiny field when i started
was not well respected by other branches
other physicists and astronomers
so now gravitational physics is
established and you know you should if
it excites you
you should do it very good and nico what
are you most excited about
and being perplexed by and challenging
your students to think about these days
well so i i i always tell my students
especially
the first years that approach me or even
the undergrads that they should really
think
deep and hard about what it is that
excites them the most
what wakes them up at night uh
or you know when they wake up in the
morning they look forward to
investigating where is their passion and
they should always be asking that to
themselves
and they should just pursue whatever
area of physics
if they you know like physics of course
that
that really truly fascinates them
because that's what's going to make them
the most happy
whether there's jobs or not um
you know i think and this is my of
course personal opinion but it's
and of course like i i am in a position
of privilege because you know
um i i have a faculty position um
and i managed to to to do what i wanted
and get hired for
for researching what i want but but with
that said
i think you're better off at
you know having a job that maybe doesn't
pay you as much
but that makes you happy and and it
it allows you to to go to work and enjoy
what you're doing
that having a job that perhaps
is is very well paid uh but that you
hate
because that's just going to make you
unhappy and affect your personal life
and and that's no way to live yeah and
if that happens to be
relativity then great that happens to be
condensed matter
then go for it if you want to do uh
if you want to work for a defense
contractor more power to you like
you need to decide you're the one that
has all the answers
most of my former graduate students
remember receiving from me i did it
wasn't nico because he was an
undergraduate
with me at washington youth but i first
first undergraduate student comes and
wants to work with me i give them what i
call my stern lecture
way i would even wag my finger at them
saying
this is a small field there are very
very few jobs
doing general relativity in the world i
mean you could be a professor but
hardly any of them it might be work for
nasa etc
so very few jobs grant support
is very minimal but if you're willing to
accept all that that
after you graduate you might have to go
into something else computers
whatever it is get teaching
if you're willing to accept all that
then
doing a phd in general relativity will
be the most fantastic five or six years
of your life
well that's good that's my that's my
story so
has your lecture changed though in in
recent in recent years
it's pretty much the same because still
i mean
it's a gravitational physics is in some
ways a big field but a lot of those jobs
are for experimentalists
oh yeah there are a thousand people at
ligo and two-thirds of them are
engineers and
and uh you know data analysts not you
know what we would call
general relativists so i think it's it's
still it's we're still a small sub
branch of physics
with very few practical applications so
i want to conclude with a
with a statement from nico's uh
institute for
uh what is it again the institut
illinois center
for advanced studies of the universe
where you talk about the book nico and
you say we keep asking if einstein was
right
not because we think he was wrong but
because that's what physicists do
even though gr has passed every test we
devised we have yet to we
we have to continue searching for
deviations from einstein's predictions
we know einstein's theory cannot be the
final word since it remains incompatible
with quantum mechanics so he must be
missing something
newton appeared to be right for hundreds
of years before observations of mercury
suggested something was amiss
and then einstein came along and i want
to thank you guys for writing this
wonderful book which will hopefully
inspire many many graduate students to
um
to subvert their their free will
as we might say uh and and work for
physicists and work with physicists like
cliff will
the renowned cliff will and the uh and
the superstar nico yunus thank you guys
so much for spending your time with the
into the impossible podcast
and uh let our audience know where can
they find you where can they get this
book et cetera
it's on amazon.com just look ask the
question is einstein still right
and you'll find it yeah books are sold
whatever books are sold that's right we
don't want to give a monopoly to the to
the giant
river in in nico's home continent
uh nico yunus professor unis uh
professor will
thank you guys so much uh cliff you've
been a big influence on me
and and my uh my style and sort of my
interest
for many many decades it's been great to
meet you finally
uh and have this wonderful occasion nico
thank you so much my friend
it's a wonderful book i urge everybody
to get a copy of it is einstein still
right
and uh and it's available as they say
wherever books are sold
thank you both so much have a great rest
of your day and your week thank you
brian
great to meet you
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
you